wenn das so weitergeht und die Politik
sich weiter so verhält mit ihren grünen
linksgesteuerten Ideologie und damit
unser ganzes landgeistelt wir reden hier
von nicht mal 20 Prozent die die gewählt
haben und die schreiben uns vor maßen
sich an sind übergriffig wie wir hier
und zu verhalten haben Waschlappen dann
kann ich nur sagen ich merke schon dass
die Menschen einfach nicht mehr können
die Schnauze voll haben und es brodelt
und wenn die Damen und Herren im
Bundestag mal aus ihren Palästen
rauskommen würden und sich mal zwischen
die Bürger stellen würden dann würden
sie es auch merken wie sie haben bloß
Angst mit Eiern beschmissen zu werden
und bei vielen von denen leider ist
haben sie auch alles dafür getan ich
kann nur sagen wenn das so weitergeht
befürchte ich dass wir Übergriffe haben
werden und jetzt passen Sie auf das
entscheiden ist ja eins wenn der erste
Polizist zu Tode kommt oder der erste
Bürger zu Tode kommt dann gibt es Massen
und ruhen und was passiert dann setzt
man denn die Bundeswehr einen inneren
was passiert dann und dann ist es wie so
ein süßes und Dominostein der nicht
immer weitergeht und dann gibt's ja auch
welche die nur darauf warten dass die
ersten Steine fliegen und dann das
Mitmachen und davor habe ich Angst dass
das passiert wenn das immer weiter aus
der Kontrolle gerät und die Politik soll
entweder endlich handeln und zwar so
dass ich für alle nutzt oder verdammt
noch mal geschlossen zurücktreten denn
das was sie jetzt bringen ist beschämend
ist zum größten Teil asozial und vor
allen Dingen wenn sie etwas fordern
sollen sie es vormachen und das tun sie
nicht und deswegen sind sie nämlich
ultragbar bei dem was sie da abzieht
also einmal zusammengefasst sie fordern
Neuwahlen ganz ehrlich da vielleicht
wissen sie das ja nicht wir haben letzte
darüber geredet ich bin mit Marcel
Luther angetreten in Berlin wir sind
angetreten und man hat diese Wahlen
beschissen hat man da man hat gestaltet
es unterirdisch man hat ja Demokratie
mit Füßen getreten man hat man hat einen
Marathon stattfinden lassen zu einer
Zeit wenn unsere Wahl nicht mehr sicher
sind und wir jetzt darüber diskutieren
müssen ob oder nicht wiederholen
natürlich müssen die wiederholt werden
und wenn die wiederholt werden müssen
wir auch im Bundestag wieder runter und
dann wollen wir doch mal sehen ob sie
dann immer noch so gewählt wie jetzt ein
paar verstrahlte Schafe sind immer dabei
was machen Sie wenn das Wahlergebnis das
gleiche sein wird wir gehen davon
ausgehen
ich komme mit okay
Herr Freund sie haben gerade gesagt als
Herr Stahlos gelegt hat auch über die
Unruhen zu reden auf den Straßen haben
sie gesagt ganz sicher wird es passieren
ist damit die Politik trägt
Verantwortung dass wir muss darauf
reagieren auf internationale Konflikte
und diese internationale Konflikt führt
zu hören Energiepreisen zu anderen
Verwerfung der Lieferketten und so
weiter und so fort und diese
Disproportion ich bin selbst Volkswirt
und diese diskurportion muss die Politik
so gut sie eben kann eben ausgleichen
und wenn sie das nicht tut produzieren
eben solche Dinge wenn es eben
unterbleibt dann haben wir eben mit
diesen sozialen Unruhen wie wir sie aus
Frankreich kennen wie wir sie aus
einigen teilweise aus Großbritannien
kennen haben wir dann mit umzugehen und
zu leben dass sie selber Volkswirt sind
ich habe damals in meinem BWL Kursen
gelernt die Politik stellt die
Rahmenbedingungen und der Rest ist
eigentlich in der Wirtschaft das gilt
nur für die Marktseite dann haben Sie
noch die Seite des Staates der
logischerweise Dinge muss der Staat
schon viel zu sehr aus den
Rahmenbedingungen raus ist und
eigentlich wie ein Vater und wie eine
Mutter über den Bürgern wacht dann
müssen wir ein bisschen
diesen Vorgaben die wir hier eben alle
ein bisschen kritisiert haben muss sie
weniger duschen muss da ein bisschen
mehr frieren muss da weniger Auto fahren
und da mehr zu Fuß gehen dass sie eine
Sache die andere Sache ist der
sogenannte umverteilungsprozess in der
Stadt macht der Staat sorgt eben für die
Verteilung der Güter und werden immer
meine unverteilung in Deutschland das
ganz normal ist und von oben nach unten
das ist völlig okay wir müssen nur sehen
dass es nicht nur Kosten auch aber das
ist eben nicht nur die Menge ist
entscheidend sondern wir Stahl richtig
sagt es muss doch zielgerichtet sein so
gießkannten Prinzip Methoden haben wir
viele erlebt und es riesen
Ressourcenverschwendung wir werden sich
vorstellen diese 300 Euro wo er nur 160
ankommt das Frechheit und jetzt
überlegen wir doch mal die bekommen ja
sogar die 600 Leute im Bundestag was ist
da wirklich besser dann 1000 € an die
zuverdienen diese wirklich brauchen und
selbst 1000 € sind ein Witz wenn die
jetzt das fünf oder sechs oder
siebenfache an nur für sie die Menschen
die es wirklich brauchen um bis jetzt
mal zu zu ganz ganz speziell zu sagen
die Menschen die es wirklich brauchen
das sind die die wahrscheinlich schon
auch vorher die sind wir haben 14
Millionen Menschen die in Armut leben
und das wird immer mehr
werdenfänger wer sind für die die sie
die es wirklich brauchen die Menschen
die sozial schwächer gestellt sind also
da und da müssen wir wirklich gucken wer
die auch sind und es muss gerecht
verteilt werden wie wir das schon gesagt
haben aber wir haben auch Menschen die
aber da gibt's ja verschiedene Gruppen
es gibt Aufstocker es gibt Hartz IV
Empfänger es gibt ja ganz verschiedene
Gruppen 500 Sozialmaßnahmen und keine
überschautes genau also ich frage mich
halt sie haben eben selber das gießkann
Prinzip angesprochen und ich würde es
vielleicht anders
wird nicht benötigt wird fangen wir doch
mal erst an dann wegzunehmen die genug
haben besonders im Bundestag vielleicht
sogar
interessiert mich schon sehr weil zum
Beispiel die Ampel wenn sie sagen man
soll mehr den geben die weniger haben
hat dir das Bürgergeld eingeführt das
müssen sie ja dann eigentlich eine gute
Maßnahme finden ja grundsätzlich ist es
schon ein gutes Geld aber gute Maßnahme
die Frage ist wie viel von den Bürgern
sind denn vielleicht auch wieder besser
gestellt und brauchen es weniger und
welche brauchen es mehr man sollte schon
differenzieren und gucken darauf gucken
dafür ist ja wir haben gerade 520.000
freie Jobs in diesem Land muss man nicht
eher schauen wie man die Menschen in
Arbeit bekommt anstatt mehr zu verteilen
das wäre schon gut dann muss die Arbeit
aber auch lukrativ sein wir haben das ja
mittlerweile schon so dass viele
Menschen ich weiß nicht wie weit wir das
jetzt mitgeschickt das schon mit viele
Menschen sagen sich warum soll ich denn
noch arbeiten gehen wenn
aber das liegt auch an der Politik wenn
wir jetzt doch ganz einfach das
Sozialstaat versagt jeden Tag und so mit
Umverteilung können sie nicht ziehen das
ist eine uraltes Missverständnis dass
sie Einkommensunterschiede und
wohlstandsunterschiede bei Umverteilung
hinkriegen wenn man Rockefeller
enteignen würde hätte jeder Amerikaner
vielleicht 50 Cent für mich reichen
deswegen das umverteilungskonzept eine
Banalität und wissen sie dass das zum
Prinzip dieser Regierung geworden ist
ist nur ein weiteres Versagen übrigens
glaube ich nicht dass es zu Unruhen
kommen wird es wird zu unrund kommen
aber es wird kein Straßenkampf geben die
Leute sind müde müssen Sie
wahrscheinlich viel besser als ich die
sind einfach damit absorbiert und
beschäftigt ihren täglichen Kram zu
regeln sie haben nicht mehr die Kraft
auf die Straße aber sie haben auch nicht
mehr den sie haben auch nicht mehr das
Geld teilweise zu überlegen was sie zu
bezahlen kann und schauen Sie mal wenn
sich überlegen Mieter oder solange ja
immer dieses schöne solange der Deutsche
immer noch sein Fußball in sein Bier hat
ja ja mittlerweile kann er sich schon
nicht mehr den Fernseher leisten und der
Bier wird immer teurer und was ich daran
immer so also extrem verwerflich finde
der
wir reden immer davon was der Staat
alles tut wisst ihr liebe Starts Diener
ihr vergisst immer eins bei jeder
Preiserhöhung alles was teurer wird haut
ihr eure Steuer auf warum passt sich
eure Steuer eigentlich nicht den
preisverhältnissen an ich meine überall
19 Prozent hier darf der Energiesteuer
das jetzt jede Stadt wenn das musst Du
angepasst werden Öffentlichkeit
erreichen die begeistert ist weil sie
einen neuen euro-ticket bekommt und dann
transportiert wird unter Umständen die
bei jedem Viehtransport verboten werden
würden nein das Sozialstaat versagt weil
er viel zu viel versuchter zu leisten
über 50 Prozent der Staatsbudgets gehen
auf soziale Zwecke Forschung
Wissenschaft Hochschulen Bildung haben
viel einen viel geringeren Anteil an
Staatsausgaben als die Bekämpfung der
Armut und es gibt der seltsame
Korrelation vielleicht können Sie mir
das erklären als Volkswirt ihr mehr
Sozialhilfe im Sommer Armut er kann doch
was nicht stimmen hier würde ich auch
gerne einmal erfreut Fragen ist ist der
ganz einfach ein wahnsinnig schlechter
Unternehmer er muss gar kein Unternehmer
sein wir nehmen ja genug Stollen ein wir
sind auf Platz zwei bei dem steuern also
der Vergleich hinkt so ein bisschen der
Staatsbürger kann Unternehmer sein er
muss Staatsaufgaben wahrnehmen die
außerhalb der unternehmerischen
Tätigkeit sehen also nur eine reine
soziale Flankierung das muss er machen
du musst zielgerichtet sein ich glaube
das Problem dann dürfte auch nicht die
Deutsche Bahn zum Beispiel staatlich
sein da müsste man vielleicht auch
Flughafen bauen
also staatlicher ist in der Stadt sind
nur Eigentümer die Bahn ist ja selbst
privatisiert und wird nach privaten
Regeln geführt sie ist ja nur im
Staatsbesitz also nur das Besitztum
macht sich zum Staatsunternehmen das ist
ja aber da müssen wir jetzt schon mal
ganz ehrlich bleiben also es ist nicht
wie ein privates Unternehmen ich würde
jetzt nicht sagen
jetzt in der Krise und wurde ja auch
nicht geführt wie eine Behörde also man
muss kein Unternehmer sein sagen Sie der
kriegt also Steuergeld und soll nur
Flanken machen er muss nicht gucken wie
Haushalten
und Unternehmertum nochmal eine Staat
soll nicht als Wettbewerber auftreten
Gottes Willen das soll eigentlich tun er
soll nicht produzieren er soll nicht
verteilen aber er muss regeln das muss
er machen und er muss vor allem den
begrenzen und er muss zielgerichtet die
die Gruppen ansprechen aber er soll
nicht als Unternehmer als Konkurrent
auftreten das tut die Bahn nicht dass du
die Lufthansa nicht das tun viele andere
auch nicht schlecht für etwas Konkurrenz
ganz förderlich wenn man sich manche
Betriebe anguckt als Unternehmer
auftreten das ist dann ist eine ganz
teure Veranstaltung und diese Leute
könnten beispielsweise keine kaum
vorstellen aber ich gebe einfach die die
Frage was sind denn die Ursachen wir
haben es gerade schon bei Herr Bruder
probiert zu klären mit Herr Stahl
darüber debattiert das Geld ist ja da
also wenn Politiker hier in der Runde
sitzen sagen sie meiner ja Geld haben
wir eigentlich wir brauchen nicht mehr
Steuereinnahmen wo liegt also das
Problem ich meine das frage ich mich
auch ich bin Schriftsteller und ich bin
eigentlich auf der anderen Seite und
sozusagen also als Freiberufler ich
meine in Deutschland redet man nicht so
viel über Gehälter ich bin in
Deutschland nicht sozialisiert also ich
sag mal da irgendwas dazu und zwar als
beruflicher wenn ich ein Artikel
schreibe für eine angesehene Zeitung in
Deutschland und das ist ein Reportage
also ich muss irgendwo Reisen ins
Ausland ich muss da recherchieren dann
komme ich zurück schreibe ich die ganze
Interviews auf und dann schreibe ich den
Text das ist drei drei Wochen Arbeit
sagen wir mal alles insgesamt und das
sind zwei Seiten dann in einer Zeitung
und ich krieg dafür Honorar 500 Euro und
wenn ich dann in der Zeitung Frage gibt
es da irgendwie Spesen weiß ich nicht
Reisekosten sagen sie nein das war's und
dann sagen sie okay aber sie haben doch
ein Stipendium ein literarisches
Stipendium was sie von der
Senatsverwaltung für Kultur in Europa
zum Beispiel bekommen hier in Berlin als
ansässiger in Berlin ansässiger
Schriftsteller da können Sie das doch
querfinanzieren und also das ganze
System was ich damit sagen will ist also
für meinen Beruf jetzt gesprochen für
viele freiberufliche Künstler
Kulturmenschen ist so konstruiert dass
die Wirtschaft nicht genug Geld abgibt
um diese Leistung die von uns quasi
angekauft wird weil in Artikel wird von
mir angekauft ja ich mache irgendetwas
produzieren was das wird gekauft aber
das Geld was dabei bekommt ist in keinem
Verhältnis zu dem ich mal 500 € kann ich
ja auf jeden Fall schlecht kommen genau
und aber die Wirtschaft rechnet dann
damit okay der Staat hilft nach bei der
Berlin hilft nach ja und dann frage ich
mich auch also wie soll das
funktionieren und gleichzeitig aber wenn
ich die Frage an die Unternehmen also
sowie die Medien jetzt irgendwie die
meine Arbeit einkaufen in die Wände und
Frage haben sie nicht mehr Geld dafür
was ne haben wir nicht dann dann
schreiben sie halt keine Reportage
schreiben Sie Publizistik